you film jury
and Kerry Wood
they talk with you
we took the decision at that moment to
to quit for a while so we dropped out
for or maybe they asked us to Christmas
anymore either that they may have thrown
us out we can't remember it ended up
that we we really for two years we just
kind of out we didn't have an agent we
had no you know no professional kind of
you know the situation set up but during
that time we couldn't stop writing we
just found ourselves anyway still
wanting to write and one of the things
we wrote during that time was the script
for paper man this was back in 2004 and
it really reinvigorated us it was so
fantastic at that moment for us to be
writing purely for ourselves we had no
agenda we thought you know what if we
like this script when we're done maybe
we'll make it on a credit card with some
actor friends you know we really were
doing it for the sake of doing it and
that really got our juices flowing again
and so oddly enough paper man was the
thing that kind of got us out of our
writing doldrums and I'm fully those
back up it's the thing that sort of got
us strange enough in typically into this
into the studio system the one if
there's one thing that we've sort of
learned by working in the studio system
particularly is that you have to work
your butt off it's eight the more you do
the more you're doing then the next guy
the better you're going to do in the
longer you're that the more desirable
you are if you if you'll work yourself
like a mule it pays off it's actually
you have to work and work and work and
write and write and write and there's no
such the Malcolm Gladwell book what is
it 10,000 hours people it's real yeah
putting the time itself it's just how I
said a joke going going come and go